Anderson
grupo Grupo que salió chicos Carlos Cruz
es guía va a acompañar a un grupo hasta
las profundidades de un cañón que llega
a los 120 metros ve la que nosotros
recomendamos es esta posición
muy cómodas Pero siempre y cuando tener
las manos prestas hasta hace poco más de
un año no era habitual ver turistas en
la zona
bastante esta parte y le queda más
dicen que en los llanos de Colombia Se
mira lejos a diferencia de la Cordillera
pero no hace tanto el conflicto armado
escondía las Maravillas naturales del
departamento del meta en el centro de
Colombia como El Cañón del guape no es
que ni siquiera la cascada del amor que
queda cinco minutos la podíamos conocer
Pues por el tema de minas por el tema de
conflicto los alrededores pertenecían a
uno de los grandes comandantes de las
FARC alias romaña
por lo que el cañón fue explorado por
primera vez en 2016 después del acuerdo
de paz de la guerrilla y el estado es un
cañón que
es único por sus diferentes tipos de
rocas que tiene por sus diferentes tipos
de figuras de su contorno de su altura
de su vista por eso es único
Carlos tiene 31 años es desplazado y
víctima del conflicto armado su hermano
entró en la guerrilla y nunca más
tuvieron noticias
los jóvenes de la Uribe encuentran en el
atractivo que despierta el cañón una
alternativa a la violencia no la primera
vez que bajé uno baja de locos o sea
esto es algo que usted dice Guau esto
Realmente está en mi municipio está can
Uribe como quien dice no me lo creo
las FARC tenían gran poder en la Uribe
de ahí la desconexión con el estado una
herencia palpable en sus vías precarias
Este era un punto estratégico para la
guerrilla a los pies de la Cordillera
Oriental las montañas rodean a la Uribe
y la separan del oeste del sur y de
Bogotá tránsitos de difícil acceso a
miles de metros de altura por allí la
que fuera la guerrilla más grande de
América Latina llegó a sitiar la capital
del país en los últimos ocho años el
departamento del meta ha vivido la
deforestación de
247.000 hectáreas dos árboles han sido
sustituidos por vacas la ganadería ocupa
un 13% de la actividad económica
regional
Eso era lo que había y cinco casas
de de de gente fundadores Natanael rojas
llegó a la Uribe cuando todo era selva
era el año 1966 su familia buscaba
tierras fértiles
esto es una de las herramientas de
trabajo de las más necesarias de aquí en
el llano el caballo también llegó a la
Uribe escapando de la violencia pero
esta pronto apareció para perseguirle el
resto de sus días
Natanael llegó a ser detenido acusado de
administrar la ganadería de las FARC
después de 82 años nunca se ha ido pese
haber estado en el centro de la guerra
no me daba miedo porque exactamente
yo consideraba que que yo no no tenía
por qué irme de una región donde
había logrado hacer en la juventud lo
que tenía hoy en día y yo pensaba en eso
si me voy pues tengo que acabar con todo
dejarlo ahí votado
en la finca de atanael Siempre hubo una
joya
Esta es la famosa cascada del amor
Natanael nunca pensó que su casa podría
ser un lugar atractivo para personas de
todo el mundo aquí es donde llegan los
turistas
a disfrutar de
de esta belleza y pone sus esperanzas en
La Paz total del nuevo gobierno con el
sueño del fin de un conflicto de más de
seis décadas
Natanael como la Uribe escribió su
historia en las sombras ahora
silenciando los fusiles espera que la
antigua capital de las FARC se convierta
en la capital del turismo
[Aplausos]